like i've been thinking this all along
and i didn't say it this time you know
why because it is a very difficult
type rope to walk
because it's not my responsibilities i'm
not that guy like i'm that's not who i
am you know i'm not here to bring the
news to the world
but if i was i certainly would speak my
mind more but people are dying it's
awful it's [ __ ] awful what's going on
there right but that being said it is
not black and white and this guy's
linsky is no freaking um you know he's
no um just you know stellar you know
person that represents democracy
not that i want to give these freaks any
ideas but when they bring kovid back i
just know they're bringing it back did
they screw up something in the sales job
because after the two weeks to flatten
the curb thing i kind of realized it was
all nonsense i knew the old world wasn't
coming back i didn't believe them i
didn't believe the body language the
messaging the commercials everything
based on fear i mean should they have
done something different sal what should
we watch out for i guess is what i'm
asking you here's the problem you know
is that um
when you it's not so much sales but
brainwashing that was going on and when
you're brainwashing people or trying to
create a certain culture or a thought
culture right
there's this side to it it's number one
the constant reinforcement of one
message it's a constant reinforcement
but barning a message danger danger you
know death death death you stay home say
you know stop every world is changing
but there's another side to it too you
have to squash
all other competing messages and that's
where the platforms came in and they
literally stopped free speech and they
made it so you could only hear one
message that brainwashed people but even
that i think there was p you know listen
there was many people like almost had no
choice i mean like the society just
literally you know they they virtue
signal loss to like to be rational
people to death but like it was like
are were like
you actually believed this [ __ ] like it
was it was ridiculous like you know you
know am i gonna believe my eyes or the
nonsense i'm hearing in the in the
present by the way it's still going on
right now with other things i have
literally it just shocks me
like the lack of legitimacy
on tv with the news it's just it's like
what do we do what do we do i mean
that's what literally shows like what's
going with ukraine i think what putin
did was terrible but there's there's
more than one side to the story for sure
yeah and and that's awful it doesn't
mean like that it's that he shouldn't be
you know um you know thought of as you
know as a bad guy for invading a country
but it's just like i don't know like you
know oh so you're a putin apology
exactly
yeah you said something with nuance what
are you nuts but i saw a really
interesting interview with on tucker and
i knew that before like i've been
thinking this all along and i didn't say
it this time you know why because it is
a very difficult
type rope to walk
because it's not my responsibility it's
not i'm not that guy like i'm that's not
who i am you know it's i'm not here to
bring the news to the world
but if i was i certainly would speak my
mind more but people are dying it's
awful it's [ __ ] awful what's going on
there right but that being said it is
not black and white and this guy
zelinski is no freaking um you know he's
no i'm just a you know stellar you know
person that represents democracy and he
just banned 11 political parties lefty
political parties why but why in the
name of democracy why isn't the news
talking about this i think because they
want to do it here too and they're just
running the test the test game i mean i
know that all sounds nuts but well that
that's a good one is there anything that
i could say or anything that you would
hear that you'd be like nah that can't
be right like that everything is so out
of whack right now
that it's like you believe anything it
seems pretty obvious this is the
military industrial complex doing what
they do best
war
weapons destruction
um like this guy zielinski is saying
we're on the verge of world war three
over ukraine yeah why
it's like not even a strategic point for
us like why is ukraine what about what's
going on in syria or yemen like there's
all these other slaughters around the
world yeah or what we did to iraq or
afghanistan like
like why is this suddenly why are we
supposed to go to war and start world
war three
over ukraine as bad as i think what's
happening in ukraine i'm not saying it's
not terrible and i'm sympathetic to the
people and i've been to ukraine many
times now amazing people but
like you know
i'm not interested in starting world war
three over this what do you make of how
they change the messaging so quickly so
like the state of the union it's like
biden does a half hour on ukraine to
start as he's standing in there with no
masks pelosi behind him she's 900 he's
800 and that the average american is not
walking around thinking about ukraine
that often and again that's not
diminishing what's going on there and
you can't just invade a sovereign nation
but like
how do they the messaging of how they
flip it right
they flip it so quickly and get
everybody's eye on something else it's
shocking it's it's it's really shocking
and i think that the most shocking part
is probably always like this it's just
that we live in a world now where it's
very hard to not have things be
transparent the manipulation was always
there we always
along for the days of walter croc he was
probably just as bad you know it's like
so i just think that right now it's like
really hard to hide anything so you have
these sort of you know more discerning
minds that are just saying [ __ ] they
call [ __ ] and i think those minds
were out there before but they had
nowhere to call [ __ ] so you have
social media about the platforms where
people could have voices so the
dissenting at least gets out there
somewhat before it's squashed it's it's
so funny because we've done each other's
shows a bunch of times before and
whenever i when i've had you go over for
dinner or whatever it's like we can do
the politics thing and it's funny to me
that you sort of talk about politics but
you could if you never talked about
politics again you'd be fine i don't
really like i don't listen i'm very much
into politics
but it's not where i you know my
heartbeat is not in politics i intrigues
me
in the sense that you know it's the most
corrupt
um
shockingly corrupt you know institution
and
what's happened is is that
the press and the attack squads have
created a paradigm where no one that
really has anything good going on wanna
run it for office like trump i couldn't
believe he did it like i mean i don't
maybe he didn't realize what he was
getting himself into but like why would
you run for office like it's just the
most evil thing that it's like they dig
up any dirt that you have it just it's
all about undermining you tripping you
up discrediting you
it's it's shocking it's like almost like
the gestapo is on both sides just trying
to destroy destroy propaganda and it's
not about truth and it's not about
making the country a better place i
really think that the u.s has seen its
better days and ain't coming back i
don't think so so so do you see any way
out of this like to me i see that
there'll be pockets out where we are
right now miami is the future florida is
the future i think there's there's like
a base there and all the people moving
and they get it
why they're moving here texts moving
here i think there's a there's a bullish
attitude here but i think a lot of it is
gone do you think do you think it's gone
all together or it's just going to so
let me let you get into the greater
what i mean so
what happens is
rich people
people that not just the rich rich but
just people that make money they're
always going to make money and they're
always going to live good lives they're
survivors
people that are going to be really poor
are always going to be dirt poor because
they just have a dirt poor mentality
they they don't want to do anything to
get themselves out of poverty but then
there's all these other people that
really work hard in the middle class
those are the ones that are getting
squeezed the most those people are
having the american jeep romp from them
so like to me it doesn't matter to me at
all it doesn't matter you're always
going to make a lot of money you're
you're at that point where you oh but
you make a little bit more this doesn't
matter you get the life you want but i
think what happens is it's the people in
the middle
that really really suffer and you know
the
dollar
buys less and less
job opportunities becoming you know
scarcer and scarcer and
this vocism i think is the death of of
so much
liberty in this country and it's like i
look at this this class means the
picture of that of the swimmer
says it all you look at her she's seven
feet tall and the little girls are
cowering and i can and people just don't
stop that like the country has lost its
moral compass she has a penis by the way
she does she has a penis she has still
yeah she's still got the penis so the
girls in the locker room are not happy
because she walks around and she's got a
penis really and we're saying she right
because you're trying to be respectful
at some level it's like a rudder maybe
if
but like something you know what i mean
it's like you're trying to be respectful
i i know you you are right right so
you're using this
but you're also mocking the reality of
we this is a big dude who in effect is
crushing these girls and the feminist
terrible
here's the thing though like you want
your daughter around that age right why
do i call her she
it's no skin if she wants to be cold she
how cool is she it doesn't
it doesn't bother me i don't care yeah
like if that's what you want to be
called she or or a big fat glute i'll
call you that too i don't care what you
want to be called like i don't care
about labels like that so that makes her
happy that makes her happy i guess some
people will say no and she's a he and
and i won't refuse to i don't care like
i'm sympathetic i want her to be as
happy as she can or whatever you want to
call or write it but now it's at the
expense no but not even now this is just
nonsense it's [ __ ] pure nonsense
and if you don't know that
you're sick you're crazy like if you
don't know that that's patently unfair
it's beyond obvious it's it's it's
patently ridiculous
how could this be allowed if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell